what the egg is my class project what
are you talking about
the egg is my baby I'm supposed to take
care of it for a weekend to give a
report on what his legs be a father
so what's it doing in my refrigerator
just chilling
you're not funny
I'm just gonna leave it in there until
it's time to turn it in and give the
report oh you know what I'm gonna say
it's easy hey
an easy a so you think that taking care
of a baby is easy no it's not a baby
it's an egg but your assignment is to
take care of this egg as if it were a
baby do you think I left you in the
refrigerator whenever I had something
else to do is it bad
not if you got a thousand dollars ain't
that right baby
[Applause]
break time baby
break time
you are gonna do this assignment and
you're gonna do it right damn
I have an announcement to make we have a
new addition to the family what you
having a baby he ain't sleeping in my
room I'm not having a baby Chris did I
thought you said we bring home a baby a
slap the Similac out of us it's been a
real baby
an egg it's Chris's new school project I
oh cool so what's the baby's name I
didn't really name it can we call him
Junebug Jumba man what kind of name is
Jumba it's better than what I was
thinking of the Incredible Edible baby
I'm gonna show you just how hard it is
to raise a baby and if any of y'all
catch Christmas treating this child you
better let me know because if you do
you're gonna get a lot worse than the f
don't you hear that baby crying you feed
him first and then you eat now get that
screaming child out of here if this
happened now I tried to get Madonna to
adopt my egg my mother decided to make
sure I got the full baby experience so I
didn't bring home a real one Chris wake
up the baby's crying what's wrong you
got to change his diaper
Chris wake up the baby's crying he's
hungry
[Music]
Chris the baby's crying is it hungry no
is it what no the flowers he's got gas
foreign
[Music]
bug she didn't count on one thing a
ladybug hey Chris can you help me carry
some of my bags home oh Mom can I help
her carry some of her bags huh go ahead
thanks
for Where Have You Been you've been
going for almost an hour I thought you
went AWOL how far does that girl live
you slept the block
but here none of the package for you
take this to miss Perkins
hey
we'll Black Ops Black Op June bug is in
there with my egg
I'm sitting right here
well I don't know I've been packing bags
all day that thing could be anywhere
man Junebug was the first egg to ever
end up on a milk cart
I lost my egg oh that's not your egg no
this is the one I took from the
refrigerator when I lost the other one
wait a minute you got me here like
Colombo trying to figure how my food is
disappearing and it's right there in
your hand I'm scared to tell you what
happened I don't want you to get mad see
Chris that's my point if your real child
were missing would you hide it from me
yes no would you steal a white kid and
paint them Brown yes no sir so you
thinking about the wrong thing the
hardest thing about being a father is
not learning how to care for somebody is
learning how to quit thinking so much
about yourself you know I can't let you
go to class with the fake egg but I'm
going to get a f
no you're not
June bug what monk bought it over
apparently when you weren't paying
attention it got mixed in with another
customer's groceries well why don't you
tell me you had it why didn't you tell
me you lost it
here
and the next time you bring a baby in my
house you better bring his mother and
she better be your wife
[Music]
foreign